wir bleiben beim Thema Energie wie den
ganzen Nachmittag muss man fast sagen
also auch bei dem nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da wird es gehen um
die krisengewinne von Energiekonzernen
und wie die beispielsweise abgeschöpft
werden sollen wie es die Linke
vorschlägt hier in einem Antrag erster
Redner zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
Markus hier Brand für die FDP haben sich
ebenfalls seit dem Mai nicht verändert
es gibt wirklich keine objektiv
anwendbaren Abgrenzungskriterien welche
Unternehmen da überhaupt in Frage kämen
und insbesondere welche Teile des
Gewinns dieses Unternehmens dann
übergewinne versteuert werden sollen
diese Schwierigkeiten alleine führen
schon dazu dass die übergewinnsteuer
rechtlich kaum durchsetzbar
ausgeschaltet werden kann wer nicht zur
Unrecht stößt eine solche
willkürmaßnahme auf massive auch
verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken
gerade das Beispiel die Zahlen zeigt uns
was passieren kann wenn man solche Ideen
nicht ganz bis zum Ende denkt doch
scheitert der Versuch eine
übergewinnsteuer auf der Basis von über
Umsätzen zu installieren gerade krachend
jetzt fehlt sogar noch Geld in der
Staatskasse und daran sollten wir uns
kein Vorbild nehmen deshalb bleiben wir
dabei wir werden die übergewinnsteuer
ablehnen dennoch erkennen auch wir dass
es zur Zeit keine funktionierenden Markt
im Energiebereich gibt und diese
ungewöhnlichen Zeiten erfordern deshalb
auch unserer Meinung nach Maßnahmen die
erstens
Gewinne von Unternehmen begrenzen die
ohne eigenes Objektives
unternehmerisches Handeln derzeit gerade
zu explodieren die zweitens dazu genutzt
werden können Menschen die
Schwierigkeiten haben die Rechnungen für
Energie zu bezahlen zu unterstützen und
drittens wichtig so auch ein Beitrag zum
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden der Menschen in
Deutschland leisten können
die Menschen brauchen ein Signal das ein
schnelles Signal aus meiner Sicht das
für sie mit ihren Sorgen derzeit nicht
alleine lassen und deshalb hat die Ampel
im Rahmen ihres dritten
entlastungspaketes eine strompreisbremse
beschlossen die zurzeit mit Hochdruck im
Ministerium von Robert Habeck
vorbereitet wird
und auch auf europäischer Ebene
wird ähnliches vorangetrieben die
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen hat in ihrer Rede zur Lage der
Union entsprechendes angekündigt der
Ansatz den die Ampel dabei wählt
verschont das Steuerrecht von einer
weiteren in Anspruchnahme durch
Politiker für willkürlich selbst
definierte Zwecke wenn wir regeln es
eben nicht über das Steuerrecht sondern
über einen Eingriff in das sogenannte
strommarkt-design dieses Design führt
zurzeit zu erheblichen zufallsgewinnen
weil sich der Preis auf dem Strommarkt
immer nach dem teuersten Produzenten
richtet zur Zeit also auf der Basis der
völlig abgehobenen Gaspreise
diesen teuren Strompreis erhalten aber
auch die Produzenten von Strom die dafür
gar kein Gas einsetzen also
beispielsweise Strom durch Kohle
gewinnen oder auch durch Windkraft
an dieser an diese derzeit nicht
funktionierende Grundkonzeption werden
wir deshalb rangehen und auf der Basis
von festgelegten erlös-obergrenzen
werden Gewinne definiert die keine
operative Ursache haben sondern wenn Sie
so wollen zufällig entstanden sind und
diese Mehrerlöse werden wir dann nutzen
auch um energiepreisssenkungen auf
breiter Front für Handel handwerk-
die Idee einer übergewinnsteuer sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ist ja nur eine
von mehreren Vorschlägen aus der linken
Ecke unseres Hauses neue beziehungsweise
höhere Steuern durchzusetzen
sie ist aber die vermutlich schlechteste
Idee weil sie uns für die Zukunft in
eine Abhängigkeit bringen würde dass
irgendwo zwischen Stammtisch und
Linksfraktion entschieden würde wer wann
welche übergewinne erzielt und wie hoch
diese zu besteuern werden
das ist die vermutlich schlechteste
Aussicht und dies allein ist schon Grund
genug diesen Antrag voller Überzeugung
abzulehnen
ja das sagt Markus herbrandt von der FDP
zu dem Antrag der Linksfraktion einen
Teil der außerordentlichen krisengewinne
von Energiekonzernen abzuschöpfen er hat
es ja auch angedeutet die Ampelkoalition
hat aus dem übergewinn von
Energiekonzern einen zufallsgewinn
gemacht das ist Teil des dritten
entlastungs-paketes und da haben Baden
die ampelkoalitionäre vor allem ja die
Stromerzeuger im Blick da werden wir
noch mehr in der Aussprache hören jetzt
erstmal zu Fritz Günzler für die
Unionsfraktion der amerikan
einfach Debatten über die Folgen des
brutalen Angriffskrieges Putins gegen
die Ukraine und den Folgen auf den
Energiesektor die Preise steigen es gibt
erhebliche Belastungen für alle Menschen
in unserem Land aber insbesondere auch
für viele Unternehmen insbesondere in
der Handwerksbetriebe die bis jetzt bei
der Ampelkoalition bis jetzt keine
Berücksichtigung gefunden hat wo wir
hoffen dass da noch einiges passiert wir
erleben das nicht nur die Gaspreise
steigen sondern auch die Strompreise
also die mehr die wir am Anfang gehört
haben es gebe nur einen Wärme- und
gastproblem und kein Stromproblem ist
glaube ich ausgeräumt also wir haben
eine deutlich hier Signale dass auch der
Stromsektor betroffen ist und wir alle
haben jetzt gelernt auch diejenigen die
sich zuvor nicht so viel damit
beschäftigt haben wie kompliziert die
Preisfindung auf dem Strommarkt ist
mehrere order Prinzip
grenzpreisverfahren ein Verfahren für
diejenigen die sich noch nicht damit
beschäftigt haben das
gewährleistet sozusagen dass der
teuerste Strom den Preis bestimmt für
den gesamt erzeugten Strom was natürlich
dazu führt dass diejenigen die niedrige
Grenzkosten bei der produzierung des
Stroms haben einen höheren Preis
bekommen und damit auch höhere Gewinne
bekommen das Problem liegt also jetzt
nicht im Steuerrecht sondern es liegt
eigentlich in der Findung eines
Strompreises und von daher ist es glaube
ich richtig sich an die Wurzel des Übel
zu machen und darüber nachzudenken wie
wir zu einem Mechanismus kommen das
tatsächlich Strompreise ehrlich und fair
ermittelt wird dann hätten wir das
Problem gar nicht was die Linken hier
heute adressieren und von daher ist es
auch zu begrüßen der Kollege hermann hat
darauf hingewiesen dass wir genau da
anfängt ob nun das was im
Koalitionsausschuss beredet worden ist
weißer letzter Schluss war mit der
negativen EEG-Umlage das werden wir uns
alles angucken und der Kollege Herbrand
hat ja gesagt das Wirtschaftsministerium
arbeitet auch an dieser Sache Herr
Kollege Wenzel aus Niedersachsen mit
Methoden und Druck und ich hoffe da geht
es auch Ergebnisse geben und dann stellt
sich eben die Frage wenn es dieses
Problem gibt ist das Steuerrecht die
richtige Instrument diesem Problem sich
zu nähern und die Abgrenzungsfragen von
guten und schlechten gewinnen sind
angesprochen worden was sind eigentlich
über ihre Gewinne wo fangen sie an wo
hören Sie auf welche Branche betreffen
sie wie berechne ich sie quantitativ und
ich möchte jetzt auch noch mal deutlich
herausstellen dass wir glaube ich mal
vergessen es wird so ein Eindruck
erweckt dass diese übergewinne derzeit
überhaupt nicht besteuert werden auch
diese übergewinne also wie jeder Gewinn
wird besteuert bei der
Kapitalgesellschaft in Deutschland in
weit über 30 Prozent so weit die
sozusagen im Unternehmen bleiben und bei
Personengesellschaften die haben ja eben
gerade Debatte gehabt über das
inflationsausweisgesetz bis zu 50
Prozent also von daher wird es dort
kommt es dazu Besteuerung und dann muss
man sich auch die zweite Frage stellen
wenn man jetzt die Konzerne die die
Linke hier im Blick hat tatsächlich
besteuern will ob man über einen
Besteuerungsrecht hat ob die überhaupt
in Deutschland ansässig sind ob man
überhaupt an die Gewinne heran käme das
wäre ja dann die zweite Frage also von
daher müssen wir zu erklären was ist
denn diese besondere Steuer und wenn die
Linken in ihrem Antrag auf das
italienische Modell abheben sieht man
erstmal dass auch die Italiener nicht
das Problem der Gewinne definiert haben
denn sie machen es an den Umsätzen fest
weil Sie nicht genau wissen dass das
Problem nicht funktioniert und wenn man
sich mit dem italienischen Modell
beschäftigt und in Italien auch mal mit
ein paar Kolleginnen und Kollegen
spricht sieht man erstmal dass die
Einkommenserwartung weit unter dem
zurückgeblieben sind was vorher
prognostiziert worden ist und zweitens
sieht man dass viele Unternehmen ist gar
nicht bezahlen weil sie weint das ist
verfassungsfeindliche verfassungswidrig
sei und von daher auch das eine riesen
Rechtsunsicherheit ist und das ist eben
die Frage wollen wir uns das hier in
Deutschland auch gönnen denn wir haben
kein eigenes steuerfindungsrecht für
solche Steuer von daher kann man sowas
machen aber der Finanzminister muss dann
auch das Risiko tragen dass diese Steuer
wie damals die Brennelementesteuer
einkassiert wird und alles zurückgezahlt
werden muss ich weiß nicht ob man diese
haushaltsrisiken eingehen sollte
und empfiehlt sich auch die Lektüre mal
des
Gutachtens wissenschaftlichen Beirats
bundesfinanzministeriumssteuer allgemein
und ich glaube die Dinge die dort stehen
sollte man wirklich ernst nehmen es wird
davon gesprochen dass solche Dinge
innovationshemmend ist sie werden es
werden die Ressourcen abgeschöpft in
Unternehmen ja eigentlich dazu Führung
stehen sollen ihre Transformation die
wir von Ihnen ja warten zu finanzieren
wenn ich jetzt lese wir haben ja da wird
da bestimmt nachher da auch hingewiesen
eine übergewinnsteuer in Großbritannien
die Energiekonzerne haben jetzt schon
angekündigt dass sie ihre Investitionen
in erneuerbaren Energien zurückschrauben
werden ist das was Sie wollen denn ich
gehe davon aus dass sie Unternehmen die
mehr Geld mehr Liquidität haben die
nutzen um Innovationen und Investitionen
voranzutreiben und dabei sollten wir Sie
unterstützen
und ihn nicht das Geld wegnehmen also
von daher glaube ich falsches Instrument
und ich will nur eins vorgreifen weil
Sie wahrscheinlich jetzt demnächst auch
den oder gleich in den Debatte den
Verordnungsentwurf der EU-Kommission
einbringen werden Herr Kollege Goerke
jedenfalls gehe ich davon aus wo ich sie
kennengelernt habe wo ja die Kommission
versucht eine Lösung zu finden indem man
eine Abschöpfung von Umsätzen bei der
Stromerzeugung macht wenn die 180 Euro
pro Vega statt Stunde überhöhen sie
übersteigen und dann Solidaritätsbeitrag
bei über sogenannten Überschuss gewinnen
in gewissen Branchen da sind natürlich
massenhaft Fragen offen also erstmal
grundsätzlich meine ich wenn man sowas
macht ich bin ja dagegen muss man sowas
unionsweit machen weil der Strom mal
europaweit organisiert ist aber wenn
muss man auch mal klären wenn die
Kommission so einen Vorschlag macht auf
welcher Rechtsgrundlage sie das macht
wir haben nämlich das im Finanzausschuss
angesprochen die Bundesregierung konnte
uns da bis jetzt noch keine Antwort
geben und es wird bisher bezogen auf
Artikel 122 der EU-Verträge die gar
nicht dafür sind um die
Versorgungsschwierigkeiten zu beheben
wie eine übergewinnbesteuerung einer
Erlös Abschöpfung was zu Behebung der
Versorgungsschwierigkeiten zu tun hat
hat sich mir noch nicht erschlossen also
bitte zum Schluss ist die
Anspruchsgrundlage eigentlich Artikel
115 das wollen sie nicht weil dafür eine
Einstimmigkeit notwendig ist also von
daher glaube ich auch da gibt es
unsionsrechtliche erhebliche Probleme
bei diesen ordnungssatz wir werden den
Wohlwollen in dem Sinne prüfen dass wir
glauben dass er gar nicht umsetzbar ist
von daher lassen Sie den Antrag sein
lassen Sie das mit der Übergang Menschen
und ich höre jetzt auf frau Präsidentin
den einzigen zufallsgewinn den es gab
war die die regierungswahl im letzten
Jahr herzlichen Dank
Fritz Künstler war das für die
Unionsfraktion ja die EU-Kommission hat
Mitte vergangener Woche einen Vorschlag
vorgestellt nachdem Energiefirmen ein
Teil ihrer zuletzt stark gestiegenen
Gewinner abgeben sollen der Vorschlag
bringe die EU-Staaten laut
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen mehr als 140 Milliarden Euro
aufgrund unserer um auf der anderen
Seite dann Entlastung zu erzielen ein
Augen ein ihre Augen zu haben so der
nächste Redner noch mal die Ermahnung
von der Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne
Marquardt die Redezeiten einzuhalten
schauen wir mal auf die nächste Redner
paar samarvi für die SPD wir haben es
vorhin gehört in der Debatte um das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und ich
betone es noch einmal wir erleben
aktuell eine
hochdramatische Lage in Deutschland in
der sich viele BürgerInnen Bürger
soziale Einrichtungen kleine und
mittelständische Unternehmen und
Industriebetriebe mit spürbaren
Belastungen infolge des inflationsstoffs
konfrontiert sehen dazu kommen Sorgen um
die Versorgungssicherheit und
schlichtweg vor allem darum die
Energiepreise in den kommenden Monaten
überhaupt noch aufgebracht werden können
und wie Investitionen von Unternehmen
unter diesen Rahmenbedingungen gestemmt
werden können wie Sie wissen arbeitet
diese Ampelkoalition die seit ihrem
Amtsantritt multiple und gleichzeitig
stattfinde Krisenlagen wie kaum eine
andere Bundesregierung vor uns
bewältigen muss konsequent gegen die
Energiekrise und die wirtschaftlich
zugespitzte Situationen in Folge der
Auswirkungen der russischen Invasion
Getreide wir tun das in einem
international beachtlichen Ausmaß mit
entlastungspaketen mit einem
gesamtentlassungsvolumen von über 100
Milliarden Euro ich glaube unser
Bundesfinanzminister muss sich im
internationalen Konzert nicht verstecken
mit dem was wir hier in Dortmund
vorangebracht haben von denen gerade
kleine und mittlere Einkommen die
working class direkt profitieren jetzt
geht es um Zusammenhalt
jetzt geht es um Zusammenhalt in
Deutschland um eine solidarische
Bewältigung dieser tiefgreifenden Krise
ja wir sind in einer sozialen
Marktwirtschaft für Unternehmen die mit
Leistungen die mit Anstrengung die mit
Pioniergeist die mit Innovation Gewinne
machen wir sind stolz dass ein
Unternehmen wie beim Tag made in Germany
den Impfstoff als wichtigste Waffe im
Kampf gegen Corona auf den Markt
gebracht hat und damit auch hohe Gewinne
erzielt hat die es im übrigen wieder
reinvestiert in Spitzenforschung was wir
aber in dieser Lage so gar nicht
gebrauchen können sind Energiekonzerne
die nicht wegen außerordentlicher
Innovation und Leistung sondern aus dem
Zufall dieser Krise heraus sich im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die Taschen
vollmachen auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit
was sich in diesen Marktgeschehen zum
Teil vollzieht lässt Anstand vermissen
ist unsolidarisch und bricht mit den
Prinzipien der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
von Ludwig Erhard meine Damen und Herren
wir haben uns als Sozialdemokratie seit
Monaten dafür stark gemacht
sektoralkrisengewinne von
Energiekonzernen abzuschöpfen um damit
weitere strukturelle Entlastungen im
Energiemarkt für die Bevölkerung zu
finanzieren eine Erkenntnis wir haben es
gehört die in Europa schon weit um sich
gegriffen hat in Italien in Spanien in
Griechenland ja sogar in dem von den
konservativen Tories regierten
Vereinigten Königreich und ich finde es
macht keinen Sinn sich jetzt fest
zubeißen auf länderbeispiel und zu sagen
genau so würden wir es nicht haben
wollen und deswegen stellen wir uns
diese Debatte überhaupt nicht mehr da
bin ich außerordentlich froh dass wir
eine gemeinsame Linie in der
Ampelkoalition mit SPD grün und FDP
hinbekommen haben
zufallsgewinne von Energie Unternehmen
abzuschöpfen die vor dem Hintergrund der
Marit order des Marit order-systems
große Gewinne machen weil sie kein
teures Gas einkaufen und ihren Strom zu
hören Preisen verkaufen können und genau
damit wollen wir dann systemisch was
notwendig ist was höchst notwendig ist
in den Strommarkt Eingreifen über die
Stromkreis Bremse
wir sehen uns durch die Pläne der
Europäischen Kommission von
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen die Ihnen jetzt Union bestens
bekannt ist bestärkt die Brand des
notfallmechanismus an krisengewinne im
Strombereich und auch im fossilensektor
also Erdgas Erdöl und Kohle heranwill
sowie durch die Diskussion in vielen
europäischen Staaten die gerade
stattfindet um die damit
zusammenhängende Deckung der
Energiepreise dabei sind die Kommission
in ihrem offiziellen Statement allein im
Strombereich für den Mitgliedstaaten die
Chance auf Sondereinnahmen bis zu 117
Milliarden Euro im fossilensektor auf
bis zu 25 Milliarden Euro Geld das in
den Haushalten dringend zu
Krisenbewältigung gebraucht wird wir
sind
wir sind jetzt in einer absolut
entscheidenden Phase für unser Land
jetzt müssen zügig systematisch saubere
Konzepte abgestimmt werden wie man wie
mit krisengewinn von Energieunternehmen
und marktinvestitionen des Staates
strukturell Entlastung bei den
Energiepreisen für die BürgerInnen
BürgerInnen und Betriebe finanziert
werden das ist nicht völlig trivial und
dennoch müssen wir diese Maßnahmen
schnell in Gang bringen wir sind
zuversichtlich dass das in Europa und
bei uns gelingt wird und es muss gelingt
you never walk alone wir wollen und
werden diese Krise solidarisch meistern
niemand soll in diesem Winter im Stich
gelassen werden bei den deutlich
gestiegenen Energiekosten wir danken der
Linken dass wir über Ihren Antrag die
Gelegenheit bekommen diese Dinge heute
einmal auszuführen aber das Antrags
hätte es für uns als andere Koalition
gar nicht bedürft denn wir haben längst
eine Strategie vielen Dank
der die Ampelkoalition will ja
sogenannte zufallsgewinne von
Energieerzeugern abschöpfen gern mit dem
Segen der EU-Kommission da liegt ja eben
auch ein Vorschlag vor notfalls aber
auch ohne bislang gibt es diese Idee
unter dem Begriff über
Gewinnsteuer bzw das
so sagt es die Linke wenn es um die
Energiekonzerne geht die zufallsgewinne
der Ampel nach deren Plan würden sich
dann auf die Stromversorger auf die
Stromerzeuger konzentrieren
mit der Linken das letzte im letzten
Jahr haben sie die Abschöpfung von extra
Profiten von kriegsgewinnen wie sie
formuliert haben bei Amazon abschöpfen
wollen und sie wollten auch damals schon
angebliche übergewinne die in der
Pandemie entstanden sein bei wem auch
immer und in welchem Segment abschaffen
wir haben in diesem Jahr meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren eine
Staatsquote von über 50 Prozent die
höchste in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik
man kann den Privatsektor wenn man will
so schmal machen dass er den
Staatssektor nicht mehr ernähren kann in
sozialistischen Systemen ist die
Standard-
der vorliegende Antrag wurde von allen
Fraktionen im Finanzausschuss abgelehnt
allerdings aus unterschiedlichen Gründen
im Antrag bezieht sich die Linke auf die
übergewinnsteuer die in Italien
einmalig für ungefähr ein halbes Jahr
eingeführt worden war sie wird dort
erhoben auf den Anstieg des Saldos der
Ausgangsumsätze und der eingangsumsätze
ich hoffe dass in allen klar ist dass
diese Größe mit Gewinnen nichts zu tun
hat sie ist sie ist lediglich die
Differenz zwischen Umsatz und
Wareneinsatz und vernachlässigt
sämtliche andere Komponenten der
Gewinnermittlung Personalkosten
finanzierungskostenabschreibungen Kosten
für Forschung und Entwicklung
abgabengebühren und vieles andere mehr
die italienische übergewinnsteuer ist
also eine
Umsatzsteuer und damit unsystematisch
und völlig unwillkürlich sie wird im
Übrigen in Italien zahlreich beklagt und
sie wird wahrscheinlich diese diese
Klagen nicht überleben die Energiepreise
sind tatsächlich explodiert und wir
laufen Gefahr das Strom und Gas als das
Lebenselixier unserer
Industriegesellschaft und eines
zivilisierten Lebens im besten
Deutschland dass es je gab nicht mehr
bezahlt werden können
das liegt jedoch in erster Linie an der
seit vielen Jahren vollkommen verkorksen
Energiepolitik da gibt es ja eine
seltsame Einstimmung Übereinstimmung mit
den Linken wir haben bloß wohl völlig
andere Vorstellungen von einer
verkauften Energiepolitik neben äußerer
und innerer Sicherheit gibt es nichts
elementares für einen funktionierenden
Staat als die Energieversorgung zu
auskömmlichen Preisen
die sechs Atomkraftwerke die 21 noch im
Betrieb Waren produzieren 20 Prozent
mehr Strom als alle Photovoltaikanlagen
in Deutschland zusammen und das nicht
nur ab und zu und bei gutem Wetter
nachmittags um 12 sondern Tagen Nacht
und im Sommer und im Winter
diese Regierung wird nicht umhin kommen
irgendwann den Grünen Elefanten durch
das Nadelöhr der Kernkraft zu schieben
wenn Sie dieses Land nicht vollends in
den Ruinen treiben wird
die pazifistische Lebenslüge meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wurde
spätestens in Afghanistan und in der
Ukraine zerstört die energetische
Lebenslüge wird durch den ersten
Blackout in Deutschland zerstört werden
das Realitätsprinzip wird sich wenn er
unter Schmerzen und auf Kosten der
Bevölkerung irgendwann auf allen
politischen Feldern durchsetzen wer von
der AFD arbeiten
[Applaus]
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das Wort
Katharina Beck
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
seit wir diesen Antrag vor vier Monaten
diskutiert haben ist wahrlich viel
passiert doch einige Dinge haben sich
nicht verändert wir haben weiterhin eine
sehr hohe Inflation großteils aus
importierten Energiekosten und wir haben
auch weiterhin sehr hohe Gewinne in der
Energiewirtschaft ich habe es beim
letzten Mal schon gesagt Gewinne von
Unternehmen gehören ganz natürlich zu
unserer Marktwirtschaft denn sie sind
ein Motor für Ideengenerierung
Experimentierfreude und Innovationen für
die Zukunftssicherung unseres Landes und
wichtig ist jedoch das Gewinne auf
funktionierenden Märkten für
erwirtschaftet werden und dafür braucht
es Wettbewerb und gute Rahmenbedingungen
was passiert wenn Märkte dysfunktional
werden haben wir in den letzten Monaten
schmerzlich an den Energiemärkten
gesehen wir haben es aber mit zwei
grundsätzlich unterschiedlichen Arten
von hohen Gewinnen im Energiebereich zu
tun die ich der Klarheit der Debatte
wegen noch mal kurz skizzieren möchte
erstens haben wir die E-Mail übergewinne
von Mineralölkonzernen und doch
übergewinne kann man sehr gut definieren
erstens sie fallen in der Krise an
zweitens sie sind über hoch im Vergleich
zu einem Vorjahreszeitraum und drittens
sie sind leistungslos
sie sind das Ergebnis im
Mineralölbereich eines dysfunktionalen
Marktes aufgrund einer großen Marktmacht
von wenigen Anbietern der Wettbewerb ist
dort gestört und aufgrund dieser hohen
Markt macht was den Konzern möglich die
Preise aktiv über die gestiegenen
rohölkosten hinaus anzuheben und somit
ihre Gewinnmarge deutlich zu erhöhen
auch heute noch ist die Marge beim
Dieselpreis um 50% höher als vor der
Krise und das ohne eine substanzielle
Veränderung der Nachfrage das ist
leistungslos Beispiel shell hat das
seinen Gewinn im ersten Halbjahr 2022
auf 25 Milliarden Dollar gesteigert ein
Plus von 180% gegenüber dem Vorjahr und
der wichtigste Aspekt daran es sind die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die unter dieser
Marktsituation diesen übergewinnen und
den daraus folgenden krassen
Preissteigerungen leiden
und der zweite Punkt ein anderer der
Strommarkt anders als bei den
aktivgesetzten übergewinn im
mineralmarkt sind die hohen Gewinne hier
durch Putins gaspolitik gestörte
Preisbildung am Strommarkt entstanden
und kam daher für die Stromunternehmen
tatsächlich eher zufällig zustande so
bleibt unter dem Strich ein geschätzter
jährlicher zufallsgewinn von ca 50
Milliarden Euro in Deutschland allein
für Stromerzeuger aus Atomenergie und
erneuerbaren und diese hohen
zufallsgewinne schlagen auch bei den
Deutschen Energiekonzernen deutlich zu
Buche und haben wiederum ein sehr
negativen Effekt für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die die hohen Preise zahlen
müssen und da gehen wir ja ganz aktiv
ran mit unserem Entlastungspaket die
Lösung dieser zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen Probleme erfordert
anders als in diesem Antrag hier
vorgesehen auch unterschiedliche
Maßnahmen die richtigen Maßnahmen würden
sowohl von unserer Regierung im
Entlastungspaket als auch auf der
EU-Ebene mit ihrem historischen
Vorschlag vom 14.09 angestoßen zur
Lösung der zufallsgewinne im Strommarkt
ist kurzfristig die beschlossene
zufallsgewinnabschöpfung aber hier vor
Ort auch die strompreisbremse der
richtige Schritt am besten einheitlich
auf EU-Ebene langfristig hilft uns hier
aber vor allem der konsequente Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien denn sie sind
die mit Abstand günstigsten die wir
haben
die durch
dysfunktionalen Märkte ermöglichen
übergewinne an Mineralölmarkt liegt wie
gesagt am Oligopol und dem mangelnden
Wettbewerb daher ist es richtig hier
endlich das Kartellrecht zu verschärfen
und ich danke dem bmwk und den
beteiligten Kolleginnen hier für den
guten Gesetzentwurf dazu aber
rückwirkend seit kriegsanbruch und bis
zum entkrafttreten eines
wirkungsvolleren Kartellrechts die
übergewinne im mineralbereich
abzuschöpfen hat die Europäische
Kommission die Einführung eines
solidar-beitrags beschlossen ein
wahrlich historischer Schritt doch durch
diese Abgabe 25 Millionen können dabei
vielleicht erhoben werden dass die
tatsächlich für die Krisenbewältigung
genutzt werden kann da muss eine
wesentliche Schwachstelle behoben werden
und jetzt wird es technisch es geht um
die Bemessungsgrundlage diese sollte
definitiv bei den adressierten
internationalen Konzernen nicht das zu
versteuernde Einkommen sein denn die in
der EU erwirtschaften Gewinne der min
Konzerne größtenteils durch
Steuergestaltung ins Ausland verschoben
werden schauen wir uns noch mal das
Beispiel Shell an während die
Gewinnmarge des Öl- und gaskonzerns in
der EU für 2020 im Ganzen als negativ
ausgewiesen ist liegt sie allein für die
Schweiz bei ca 50%. das zeigt dort
fallen zwar kaum Umsätze an dennoch
werden hohe Gewinne durch die
Verlagerung aus anderen Ländern
ausgewiesen die Solidaritätsabgabe
könnte also großflächig umgangen werden
und das gilt es zu verhindern deswegen
sollten wir einen umsatzbasierten Gewinn
Proxy verwenden der den Gewinn auf der
Basis von eingangs- und ausgangsumsätzen
approximiert das ist fast genauso genau
und gleichzeitig können wir Umsätze
anders als Gewinne nicht in andere
Länder verlagert werden aber es geht
hier nicht um eine Umsatzbesteuerung
um eine Gewinnbesteuerung auf Basis der
Umsatzsteuervoranmeldungen die sind
leicht und unbürokratisch zu erheben und
diese historische Solidarität
damit sie keinen zahnloser Tiger wird
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
Katharina Beck für die Grünen war das
Sohn jetzt hören wir für die hier
antragstellende Fraktion nämlich für die
Linke auf deren Antrag hier debattiert
wird
Christian görger der Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik ich bin schon etwas
erstaunt wie auch vor vier Monaten liebe
Kollegin Beck haben sie heute wirklich
einen argumentativen Rittberger hier
hingelegt warum die Abschöpfung von
übergewinn aus diesem oder jedem Grund
ja angeblich nicht so richtig
funktioniert mittlerweile meine Damen
und Herren und das gehört ja auch zur
Wahrheit haben sie ja auch im dritten
entlassungspaket für mindestens eine
Fake über Gewinnsteuer ja schon beim
stromanmoderiert trotzdem muss die Frage
gestattet sein woher kommt denn nun der
Sinneswandel in der Koalition der jetzt
die FDP die Grünen und der die SPD
angehören sie sind ja nicht über Nacht
Sozialisten geworden wohl kaum ich
glaube sie haben sich nach der Blockade
mit bei der FDP politisch verrannt und
jetzt sitzt ihm das damoclash Schwert
der EU-Kommission mit dieser
Sonderabgabe
Solidarabgabe für die Öl- oder die
Gasindustrie mit der über Gewinne
abgeschöpft werden wollen im Nacken das
ist die Wahrheit und in
Kraft und insofern begrüßt meine
Fraktion außerordentlich die Pläne der
EU-Kommission die entsprechende
Leitplanken jetzt festgelegt hat Gott
sei Dank meine Damen und Herren bei der
Ampel gibt es jetzt diese Leitplanken
sonst würden möglicherweise diese
zufallsgewinnabgabe die da konzipiert
wird so stimmtrahaft ausgestaltet wie
diese gasumlage die wir ja vorhin als
Thema hatten oder die Abschöpfung würde
auch noch über Monate hinaus die zögert
werden bis dann die die sehen über
Gewinne vielleicht zu Jahr verjährt
werden insofern sagen wir ganz deutlich
das sind richtige Vorschläge und meine
Damen und Herren warum sage ich das so
klar weil sie ist in den letzten Monaten
nicht ehrlich gemeint haben sie als SPD
sie auch als grüne denn vor einem fast
halben Jahr hat Italien diese
übergewinnsteuer über die
Umsatzbesteuerung angekündigt und
umgesetzt lieber Kollege günster selbst
im konservativen Großbritannien und der
Boris Johnson
ist diese übergewinnsteuer aus
steuerrechten Steuer bei Energie und
Mineralöl Unternehmen auf
25%. festgesetzt worden gepaart mit
einer Abschreibung für Investition bei
den Erneuerbaren durchaus ein
vernünftiger Vorschlag darüber sollte
man auch nachdenken Sie meine Damen und
Herren sind von der Koalition
und speziell sie von den Grünen den
Sozialdemokraten haben eine Larifari
Unterstützung bei Blumen Worten hier in
ihren Sommer zu präsentiert und bei der
FDP gab es denn Mythen über Mythen und
da hat sich ja heute auch die Union
angeschlossen so das Mythos von
Christian Lindner ich zitiere eine
übergewinnsteuer ist eine Katastrophe
für die
investitions-investition
Innovationsklima in dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist ein
wirklicher Humbug oder mein persönliches
Highlight Zitat Christian Lindner er
kann keine übergewinnsteuer erkennen
insofern ist es jetzt bemerkenswert dass
mit den übergewinnplänen der EU die FDP
und Christian Lindner jetzt sehend
gemacht werden meine Damen und Herren es
freut mich sehr
auch wenn Sie unserem Antrag heute
überraschenderweise nicht zustimmen dass
sie jetzt indirekt unsere Forderungen
aufnehmen und bereit sind übergewinne
bei krisenprofitüren im Energiemarkt
hier anzugehen und trotzdem meine Damen
und Herren dürfte auch jedem klar sein
dass die in den letzten Jahren
stattgefunden finanzielle Umverteilung
von unten nach oben mit dieser
temporären übergewinnsteuer bestenfalls
abgeschöpft wird bzw abgeschwächt wird
den Schulen Sie bitte die klatante
Schieflage die wir in dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland haben mit
sage und schreibe 13 Millionen Menschen
13 Millionen Menschen die in Armut leben
bleibt bestehen und deshalb bleiben
unsere Forderung nach einer
Vermögensabgabe einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe für Superreiche und vor
allen Dingen für eine gerechte
Steuerreform auf dem Tisch vielen Dank
Christian Görke war das für die Linke
der hier noch mal argumentiert hat für
den Vorschlag übrigens wird auf Antrag
der Linken auch im Anschluss an die
Debatte darüber namentlich abgestimmt
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lohnt sich
glaube ich wenn man auf den ganzen
Komplex guckt mal ein bisschen
zurückzuschauen sie haben ja schon
gerade wieder ihre ganzen
umverteilungsinstrumente genannt wie sie
den Mittelstand in Deutschland eben
nicht nur die Reichen sondern den
Mittelstand in Deutschland strukturell
kaputt machen wollen dass es genau das
was wir nicht wollen und genau deswegen
werden wir auch im hochsteuer-land
Deutschland weiterhin vorsichtig mit
Steuern sein zurückhaltend damit sein
und ihre ganzen Abgaben und Steuern
werden immer in uns eine Gegnerschaft
finden wir haben aber wenn man sich
diese Krise anschaut und ich kann das ja
verstehen ich kann das ja verstehen dass
man ein Gerechtigkeitsgefühl entwickelt
das und sagt in diesem Fall oder ein
Gerechtigkeitsgefühl hat das in dem Fall
sagt es kann nicht sein dass sich da
einige die Taschen voll machen aufgrund
eines Zufalls der nun einmal eingetreten
ist es ist trotzdem nicht das richtige
auch bei allen Widerständen und bei
allen Gefühlen die dabei eine Rolle
spielen im Steuerrecht diesen Gefühlen
den Lauf einfach zu lassen und damit
strukturell Dinge zu zerstören und vor
allem falsche wirtschaftliche Anreize zu
setzen wir haben nicht die Krise die
gleiche Krise wie bei der
corona-pandemie wo es darum ging dass
wir wirtschaftlich stimulieren mussten
wo auch wir gesagt haben die
Schuldenbremse muss in diesem Fall
pragmatischer betrachtet werden wir
müssen Aussetzung wir müssen sie
aussetzen wir haben es hier mit einem
angebotsschock zu tun wo neue Steuern
die dann umverteilt werden sollen und
die Nachfrage stimulieren sollen nur zu
mehr Inflation in Deutschland führen und
damit den sozialen Kit in Deutschland
weiter zerstören bei allen Widerständen
die ich verstehen kann aus rationalen
Gründen dürfen wir das nicht machen
und die Lage ist ja auch nicht so
einfach wie einige darstellen wir haben
auf der einen Seite einige bei dem man
sagt die machen übergewinne oder wie
auch immer man das formulieren will ich
bin der festen Überzeugung es gibt keine
übergewinne es gibt Gewinne und die
werden in Deutschland schon ziemlich
hoch besteuert wir haben auf der anderen
Seite diejenigen die in eine Schieflage
geraten sind und bei dem wir darüber
reden müssen wie wir Ihnen helfen können
damit wir weiterhin Energieversorgung
bekommen und auch deswegen müssen wir
klar sagen das ganze kommt ja von etwas
das ist ja nicht einfach so vom Himmel
gefallen wir haben in Deutschland eine
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas zu hoch
bekommen die auch damit zu tun hat dass
einen in den Rändern dieses Hauses immer
wieder Putin protegiert wurde und wir
müssen jetzt dafür sorgen ich will nicht
dahin zurück wo wir herkommen ich will
nicht einfach nur den Zustand von vorher
wiederherstellen sondern wir müssen wenn
wir über internationalen Handel sprechen
in Zukunft ganz anders agieren ich will
weniger mit Russland weniger mit China
machen ich will mit der EU mit den USA
mit Japan mit Australien vielleicht
sogar mit Indien aufstrebenden Staaten
in Afrika vor allem mit Israel mit
aufstrebenden Staaten in Südamerika
zusammenarbeiten das sind unsere Partner
in der Welt und nicht die Autokraten die
im Zweifel die Wirtschaft sowieso und
die wirtschaftliche den Wohlstand ihres
Volkes sowieso unter ihr unter ihre
persönlichen militärischen Ideen Stellen
denjenigen will ich nicht länger das
Handwerk liefern sondern wir müssen auch
in Zukunft unseren Handel auf der Welt
überdenken und ich hoffe sehr dass
gerade von der Linkspartei die in ihrer
Fraktion ja sehr engen Kontakt zu den
Autokraten dieser Welt pflegt dass wir
gerade von der Linkspartei da auch
zukünftig etwas bekommen also
Entschuldigung dass man da so
rumschreien kann nach einer Rede von
Sarah Wagenknecht die wirklich eine
Schande für dieses gesamte Haus war
finde ich mindestens interessant wir
können so nicht weitermachen und ich
hoffe sehr auf Unterstützung aus der
Linkspartei das Werte in Zukunft mehr
eine Rolle bei internationalem Handel
spielen als sie es bisher getan haben
und dass sie ihre Kollegen in der
Fraktion wieder zur Mäßigung auf die
Russland in der Vergangenheit
protestiert haben
alles gewinnen insbesondere auf
europäischer Ebene werden wir angehen
das ist sinnvoll gerade beim Strommarkt
aber bitte nicht diese Gefühligkeit im
Steuerrecht sie richten damit mehr
Schaden an als sie gerade glauben
sagt Maximilian Motors für die
FDP-Fraktion erst Mitglied im
Finanzausschuss genauso wie der nächste
hier am Rednerpult das wird sein
Johannes Steininger für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
ja frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen
Kollegen der Antrag der Linkspartei ist
ja schon etwas länger in diesem Haus
ergibt uns aber heute die Möglichkeit
dass wir über dieses wirklich dringende
Thema Energiepreise auch hier noch mal
miteinander diskutieren können die hohen
Energiepreise sind auf der Sorgenliste
der Deutschen wirklich auf Platz 1
aber ich glaube sie sind auch noch nicht
wirklich angekommen weil die Sorgen die
wir derzeit erleben sind jedenfalls in
mein Gesprächen im Wahlkreis noch er
virtuell sie werden aber ganz real
werden wenn jetzt in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten die Briefe in die Haushalte
reinflattern mit der Nachzahlungen mit
den höheren Abschlagszahlungen und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier heute
darüber diskutieren und deswegen
ärgere ich mich wirklich
dass diese ampelregierung den Sommer
schlichtweg verdaddelt hat all das was
im Koalitionsausschuss jetzt von ihnen
beschlossen wurde vor wenigen Tagen
hätte im Grunde genommen im Juni Juli
beschlossen werden können damit wir in
Sondersitzung im Deutschen Bundestag das
dann in Gesetze schon machen und dass
die ganzen Kommissionen die dann
Gaspreise regulieren soll Strompreise
Deckeln soll dass die schon hätten Tagen
können weil dann hätten wir jetzt schon
die Entlastung und wir würden nicht so
viel für so viel Sorge der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sorgen wir haben es ihnen
angeboten weil hier Quatsch gesagt wird
von der SPD wir haben Ihnen als cdu/csu
angeboten dass wir Sondersitzung der
Deutschen Bundestages in der Sommerpause
machen wann wenn ich in der Situation
der größten Energie- und inflationskrise
in der Zeit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wann wäre das denn
angemessen gewesen als in diesem Sommer
und in dem Antrag geht es jetzt hier der
Linkspartei um sogenannte übergewinne
und dass man eine übergewinnsteuer wie
in Italien einführen soll eben nicht wie
in UK wie Kollege Goerke jetzt gerade
eben gesagt hat und ich verstehe auch
dass man der Versuchung sozusagen nicht
widerstehen kann dieses
Gerechtigkeitsgefühl dann auch zu
bedienen weil es eine populäre Forderung
ist aber es hat unglaublich viele
Probleme das Thema verfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken wir haben kein allgemeines
steuerfindungsrecht in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wir haben es
beim Thema Kernbrennstoffsteuer gesehen
dass es Verfassungsgericht gern auch
eine Regelung einfach mal wieder kippt
und wir dann als Bund nachzahlen müssen
das wollen wir nicht wir haben den
Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz in Artikel 3
und viele andere Punkte also aus
verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen ist so
eine Steuer wirklich sehr sehr schwer
umzusetzen dann die Frage welche
Unternehmen sind es eigentlich wer ist
denn jetzt der Krisengewinner wir
sprechen sie sprechen hier von
Energiekonzern was ist denn jetzt mit
den Rüstungskonzernen die jetzt durch
die 100 Milliarden profitieren wie ist
das denn eigentlich wie ist es denn
eigentlich wie ist es denn eigentlich
mit unseren Pharmaunternehmen mit
biontech die den Impfstoff zur Verfügung
gestellt haben was ist eigentlich wenn
wir jetzt eine übergewinnsteuer
einführen und in drei vier fünf sechs
Jahren kommt die nächste Krise dann sind
die nächsten daran sie zerstören mit
einem solchen sie zerstören mit einem
solchen Antrag die Planungssicherheit
von Unternehmen und deswegen sind wir
auch gegen eine solche übergewinnsteuer
dann wird schon erwähnt der Sitz dieser
Unternehmen ist gar nicht in Deutschland
liegen woanders wie soll das in
Deutschland gemacht werden wir haben
Profiteure insbesondere auch im Bereich
der erneuerbaren Energien durch dieses
Berufen mittlerweile kennt sie jeder
durch das berühmte merit order-system
haben natürlich diejenigen die mit die
erneuerbare Energien am Netz haben
massive hohe Gewinne aber wir wollen
doch gerade dass die auch in Zukunft
weiter investieren sehen sollten wir da
jetzt nicht den Gewinn abschöpfen die
Frage was ist das Referenzjahr es ist
ein Jahr oder wie die Kommission jetzt
vorschlägt der Durchschnitt der letzten
Jahre wie ist es dann eigentlich wenn in
den vorherigen Jahren dann auch
Sondereffekte sind ich meine wir
schlittern ja gerade von einer Krise in
die andere wir waren zwei Jahre Corona
gehabt auch mit Sondereffekten auf die
Bilanzen von Unternehmen wir haben jetzt
das Thema Inflation wie kann ich das
eigentlich miteinander vergleichen auch
diese Frage bleibt völlig unbeantwortet
und zum Schluss möchte ich schon sagen
also es wundert ein ja schon wenn am
Schluss
die Linkspartei einen solchen Antrag
hier einbringt wir müssen uns da mal
fragen wo kommen eigentlich die hohen
Energiepreise her die kommen daher dass
Putin einen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
führt und das er gegen unser Land gegen
die Europäische Union Gas als Waffe
verwendet ich fordere Sie auf machen Sie
eine Demonstration vor der russischen
Botschaft und fordern Sie den russischen
Staatspräsidenten auf das endlich sein
zu lassen weil dann haben wir auch keine
Probleme mit den Energiepreisen
Deutschland
ja jetzt kommt das jetzt kommt das oh
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt
kommt das Ohr ich habe gerade eben eine
Kachel auf Facebook gesehen eines
afd-kollegen aus einem Landtag und der
da groß jetzt
veröffentlicht hat links und rechts seit
an Zeit Demonstrationen kommt alle
Bürger auf die Straße ja ich natürlich
soll jeder demonstrieren aber gehen Sie
vor die russische Botschaft und gehen
Sie zum richtigen Adressaten und
demonstrieren sie vor bei den Russen
meines sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
alles in allem alles in allem herzlichen
Dank für die Gelegenheit dass wir auch
dieses Thema hier nochmal diskutieren
durften wir werden diesen Antrag
ablehnen und dann ganz gespannt auf das
schauen was die Europäische Kommission
sich ausdenkt wie dann die Abschöpfung
von gewinnen dann auch technisch gut
laufen kann herzlichen Dank
Johannes Steininger war das für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion ja wenn man auf eu-ebenen
schaut da könnte am 30 September
dazu eine Entscheidung fallen dann soll
nämlich die Energieminister über die
Gesetzesvorschläge was diese übergewinne
bei Energiekonzernen beim Stromerzeugern
anbelangt abstimmen
haben wir schon des öfteren über dieses
Thema gesprochen und schon 2021 ging es
um die Frage von Abschöpfung von
krisengewinnern damals ging es um die
digitalkonzerne jetzt wird der Antrag
sozusagen auf die Energiekonzerne
übertragen und als ich beim letzten Mal
bei der Einbringung eine gewisse
Sympathie für diese Fragestellung
gezeigt habe bin ich von der CDU und
dafür kritisiert worden dass so etwas so
gegen das Leistungsprinzip verstoße weil
wir mal sagen wenn das so wäre wäre es
ja okay aber darum geht es ja gerade
nicht es geht ja um übergewinne die
sozusagen leistungslos entstehen und
daher müssten meiner Meinung nach müssen
meiner Meinung nach ja auch die
digitalshüter der Marktwirtschaft das
ist ja die CDU sich ein bisschen bewegen
können denn im Notfall der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft Fritz Künstler hat recht
der sozialen Marktwirtschaft sich ab und
zu bewegen weil im Notfall ist das ja
auch eine Partei die sogar bei der
HypoVereinsbank bei der Commerzbank oder
bei der Lufthansa weit irgendwo vor
Verstaatlichungen noch nicht mal
zurückschreckt und wir sind im
Finanzausschuss gerade dafür kritisiert
worden dass das bei uniper nicht schnell
genug ginge die Verstaatlichung also es
gibt noch Bewegung Spielraum und ich
kenne Fritz Künstler als einen
lernfähigen Kollegen vielleicht kriegen
wir ja noch ein Präsenz hin ich finde
übrigens das auch wichtig der
Bundesfinanzminister hat dann anderer
Stelle davon gesprochen dass die
windenergien in der neuen Situation
freiheitsenergien sagen ich sage das
ganz respektvoll und anerkennend das ist
ein Schritt und sie sagen lieber
Christian Lindner bei der Abbau der der
der kalten Progression beispielsweise es
sei für sie eine Angelegenheit von
Anstand und Fairness und ich finde das
zutreffen aber bei den übergewinnen
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist das mindestens eine
Frage des Anstandes und der fernes dass
wir hier dafür sorgen dass
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher diese
Form der Profitmaximierung nicht
bezahlen müssen
und deshalb übrigens lieber Kollege
mortos das muss ich schon sagen dürfen
deswegen haben wir im Koalitionspapier
auch festgelegt dass der europäische
Vorschlag von dem eben schon mehrfach
gesprochen wurden ist zur Abschöpfung
von zufallsgewinn für Unternehmen eben
auch unsere Unterstützung findet und
wenn das auf der europäischen da steht
da drin können Sie nachlesen und werden
das auf der europäischen Ebene nicht
gelingt dass dann sogar national mache
und das trägt seine Unterschrift nicht
die das doch doch das ist schon so trägt
die Unterschrift und das werden wir auch
machen also sie sehen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Linken wir versuchen
den Herausforderungen der übergewinne
uns zu stellen und da der Kollege Goerke
ja gesagt hat der europäische Vorschlag
sei ihnen noch besser als der
italienische nämlich mal an werden sie
heute ihrem eigenen Vorstand nicht
zustimmen sondern vielleicht auch in die
Richtung Europa zu gehen denn das wollen
wir auch es ist ja schon darauf
hingewiesen worden ja dass wir beim
strommarktdesign etwas ändern müssen
sonst Künstler andere haben darauf
hingewiesen auf das das muss ich hier
nicht wiederholen aber ich glaube schon
dass es notwendig ist dass wir zu einer
Form von Lastenausgleich kommen und dazu
hat die EU-Vorschläge gemacht 140
Milliarden sind da im Gespräch wir
wollen diesen Weg unterstützen die Frage
der erlösobergrenzen die Frage auch
übrigens der europäischen Solidarität
das ist durchaus wichtig zwischen den
einzelnen Ländern oder den
verpflichtenden Beitrag auf Gewinne 2022
20 Prozent über Durchschnitt der letzten
drei Jahre das sind alles ganz
praktikabende Vorschläge wie ich glaube
um auf diese Art und Weise
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher von den
Kosten der
energieexplosionen sozusagen zu
entlasten das ist wichtig es ist auch
glaube ich wichtig dass hier die
Mitgliedstaaten positiv zu diesem
Kommissionsvorschlag stehen die
Energieminister glaube ich jedenfalls
sehr positiv und ich hoffe sehr dass wir
mit der Unterstützung des
Bundesfinanzministers die ist nämlich
zwingend erforderlich diesen Prozess
tatsächlich auch zum Erfolg bringen und
wir auch diese Art und Weise zu besseren
sozialgerechterinnen und verträglicheren
Energiepolitik für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger kommen ohne sozusagen
rückfallpositionen der Vergangenheit
reaktivieren zu müssen herzlichen Dank
ja und während Bernhard daltrop hier
Christian Lindner auf der Regierungsbank
angesprochen hat hat er wenn Sie das
verfolgt haben hier von der Regie schön
eingefangen zur Seite gedeutet das ist
eigentlich der Platz auf dem Robert
Habeck sitzt derzeit sein Staatssekretär
hier sehen Sie es noch mal
also die Bundesregierung insgesamt dann
wohl dafür verantwortlich wie das offene
nationaler Ebene umgesetzt wird wenn es
auf EU-Ebene keine Vereinbarungen geben
würde Jan wenzelschmidt für die AFD
jetzt sogenannten übergewinnen was
damals Krisengewinner war ist heute
übergewinnbar sie stellen richtig fest
dass Unternehmen kurzfristig von der
selbstmörderischen Sanktionspolitik der
Bundesregierung profitieren doch wäre es
ein fatales Signal an unsere soziale
Marktwirtschaft wenn sich der Staat
dadurch entstehende Gewinne aneignen
würde
ihre Wortneuschöpfung übergewinnen
versucht krampfhaft diese unerwarteten
Gewinne die durch die gleichermaßen
unerwartet rücksichtslose Energiepolitik
der Ampel verursacht worden in ein
legitimes Ziel staatlicher Besteuerung
umzudeuten so weit Exkurs in das hier
vorgeschlagene sozialistische Roboter
tun doch wie kommen diese übergewinde
tatsächlich zustande natürlich leistet
das merit order-prinzip seinen Beitrag
hierdurch erhalten an der Börse alle
Kraftwerke für ihren Strom den Preis den
das teuerste Kraftwerk verlangt bislang
funktionierte dieses System allerdings
aus einem einzigen Grund wir bezogen
günstiges Gas aus Russland nicht etwa
über Umwege und verteuert aus anderen
Teilen der Welt fernab von zweifelhaften
Moral doppelmoralabellen die für
aserbaidschanische Angriffskriege nicht
gelten der Preis war stabil und beide
Partner zuverlässig so zuverlässig dass
man gegen das eindringliche warnen aus
den USA eine zweite Pipeline durch die
Ostsee
mit den hiesigen Gaskraftwerken hatte
man keine hatte man eine Alternative zu
den überstürzt vom Netz genommenen
Kernkraftwerken geschaffen so blieb die
Netzstabilität erhalten trotz des
erzwungenen Ausbaus erneuerbarer
Energien die logisch nachvollziehbar
nichts dazu beitragen günstig
produzierter Strom aus günstigem
russischen Gas war also ein wichtiger
Aspekt bei der Sicherstellung
bezahlbarer Strompreise die
Bundesregierung hat diesen Aspekt
gestrichen Gast ist heute unbezahlbar
unsere Gaskraftwerke daher zuallererst
Kostentreiber und in Kürze vollkommen
nutzlos aus alldem folgen zwei
Forderungen erstens müssen die
Laufzeiten vorhandener Kernkraftwerke
verlängert und auch der Bau neuer
moderner und sicherer Kernkraftwerke
endlich in Erwägung gezogen werden
zweitens ist eine übergewinnsteuer für
Unternehmen die lediglich
unerwarteterweise von der
Rücksichtslosigkeit der Bundesregierung
profitiert haben abzulehnen die Gewinne
aus einer deutschen Steuer würden keinen
einzigen Bürger entlasten sondern nur
die Staatskasse füllen und das Geld ist
überall besser aufgehoben als bei dieser
Bundesregierung
[Applaus]
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort Dieter janecheckt erst der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Fritz Künstler lieber Herr steiniger die
Tatsache dass große Energiekonzerne eine
übergewinnsteuer beklagen ist nicht eine
Aussage für die Rechtsunsicherheit oder
deine Aussage dass diese Steuer eine
wirksame Steuer ist auf übergewinne und
so muss man das einordnen
wir sind in der Koalition uns einig dass
wir zufallsgewinne im Strommarkt
abschöpfen wollen deswegen gehen wir
jetzt auch mit dieser gemeinsamen
Position auf den EU
energieministerrat wenn der Markt das
funktional ist und die Produktion von
Strom sei es in Erneuerbaren Bereich sei
es bei Atomkraftwerken sei es bei
Kohlekraftwerken bei 50 60 70 Euro die
Kilowattstunde legt und der Preis bei
300 dann haben wir ein Problem und
können es nicht hinstellen und sagen das
ist uns egal das heißt wir wollen
rangehen und entsprechend auch für
sinkende Preise sorgen und deswegen ist
ein Eingriff in dieser Krisensituation
notwendig um diese zufallsgewinne
zurückzuführen an die KonsumentInnen an
die Unternehmen damit wir den
günstigeren Preisen wirtschaften können
das ist unbedingt notwendig
und im übrigen auch das Anlegen was die
Linke formuliert mit der
übergewinnsteuer ist ja ein Thema was
die Europäische Kommission jetzt sehr
deutlich adressiert übrigens mit einem
höheren Steuersatz sogar als sie es
vorgeschlagen haben nämlich 33 Prozent
auf Öl und Gas da sehen sie mal die
Frage ist nur auf Deutschland
konzentriert in Deutschland haben wir
keine Gasindustrie im einkäufermarkt die
privat ist und Rendite schreiben
momentan also den sollten wir
Bundesrepublik Deutschland besteuern
wenn Juniper in unserem eigenen Besitz
ist deswegen wird das eine Frage sein
der europäischen Solidarität und ich bin
ganz bei meiner Kollegin Katharina Beck
die aber durchaus formuliert im
Mineralölmarkt wäre das eine Option die
wir leider in der Koalition noch nicht
geeint haben aber nach der europäischen
Ebene zumindest eine Möglichkeit ist
dann daran zu gehen zu sagen im Rahmen
der Gerechtigkeit die fossilen Preise
haben uns jetzt auch in die Krise
getrieben Grund übrigens lieber AFD was
heißt Liebe nicht liebe AFD aber ist der
deutsche Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und nicht ein Handel der Bundesregierung
das ist die Problematik die wir
vorfinden und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
auch
ungerechte zufallsgewinne einbeziehen
weil wir können doch nicht die Leute im
Regen stehen lassen und sagen das ist
aber super das ist der Shell der Exon da
ein paar Milliarden mehr macht damit sie
sagen können das ist die Bundesregierung
schuld was ist denn das für eine Politik
am Ende
am Ende geht es doch jetzt darum dass
wir es aber auch schaffen Preise
runterzukriegen und da werden uns
übergewinnsteuer einen
zufallsabschöpfung nicht alleine helfen
sondern das Angebot auszuweiten
entsprechend auch auf dem einkäufermarkt
bei Gas zum Beispiel ein price Cap jetzt
auch gegenüber Russland aber auch
künftig gegenüber anderen
Produzenten von Gas auszusprechen auf
dem Strommarkt dafür zu sorgen dass das
Angebot auf der einen Seite da ist es
ist auch ausreichend da aber auch die
zufallsgewinne abgeschöpft werden also
alles sommersummarum dafür zu sorgen
dass wir mit niedrigeren Preisen im
nächsten Schritt damit wir aus der Krise
wieder rauskommen vielen Dank
und für die cduitiv
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gleicher Antrag
gleicher Umstand gleiches Ergebnis wie
schon vor einigen Wochen geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Linken noch
immer sind sie keinen Schritt weiter und
wenn sie dem nachrichtengeschehen dieser
Woche folgen dann merken sie dass sie
ihre Forderungen nach einer
übergewinnsteuer
oder das die Forderung langsam den Boden
verliert den Boden verliert und auf dem
Boden der Realität ankommt selbst das
Finanzministerium hält sich mit
konkreten Aussagen zurück zur Umsetzung
einer übergewinnsteuer und auch in der
SPD relativiert man die übergewinnsteuer
hin zu einer spezifischen Abgabe von
zufallsgewinnen bei Energieunternehmen
auf dem Strommarkt wenn ich das jetzt so
richtig gehört habe und meine Damen und
Herren vielleicht kommt so langsam auch
die Einsicht dass die
Bemessungsgrundlage die heute schon
angesprochen worden ist für die Abgabe
solcher zufallsgewinne vollkommen
willkürlich und unzureichend gestaltet
ist dass betrifft sowohl das
Referenzjahr als auch die infrage
kommenden Unternehmen wer garantiert
Ihnen denn dass die Unternehmen nicht
ausgerechnet in den Jahren die zur
Bemessung zugrunde liegen sollen nicht
große Investitionen getätigt haben und
sich damit nicht das von ihnen erwartete
Plus in der Bilanz abzeichnet
und meine Damen und Herren und lieber
geschätzter Kollege Goerke ich habe
vorher noch mal nachgeschaut sie
sprechen von von Großbritannien und in
ihrem Antrag will man ja auch die
übergewinne von Öl und Gas abschöpfen
und wenn man die Preise an der Zapfsäule
in London sich anschaut dann sind die
momentan beim Diesel bei zwei Euro 30
und bei bleifrei super bei zwei Euro 18
was bringt die übergewinnsteuer in
Großbritannien an der Zapfsäule für all
diejenigen die täglich jeden Tag in die
Arbeit pendeln müssen weil sie einfach
nicht die Möglichkeit haben
ja das mag sein aber dann Herr Kollege
Görke aber dann darf in ihren Antrag
nicht mit Öl und Gas und dann
vergleichen Sie auch Äpfel mit Birnen
wenn nein sie vergleichen Äpfel mit
Birnen wenn sie sagen in Großbritannien
hat es funktioniert da hat es eben nicht
funktioniert
was sind liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
erreichen werden ist ein massiver
Vertrauensbruch gegenüber den
Unternehmen sich verkennen vollkommen
die Risiken einer solchen
übergewinnsteuer und wenn sie die
Unternehmen bestrafen wollen die hohe
Gewinne durch Energie einfahren dann
erfassen Sie eventuell damit auch die
Erzeuger von erneuerbaren und
regenerativen Energien und da sollten
wir uns doch einig sein das wollen wir
alle miteinander nicht und das System
übergewinnsteuer schert dann wieder alle
nationalen Energieunternehmen über einen
kommen und das meine Damen und Herren
wollen wir nicht das sollte auch nichts
der Sinn sein und zudem zeigt die
Erfahrung aus anderen Ländern die vorhin
auch schon angesprochen wurde dass eine
Ausweitung einer übergewinnabgabe
übergewinnsteuer auf weitere Branchen
außerhalb der Energieerzeuger weitere
Unklarheiten ergibt und vor allem in der
Rechtsmäßigkeit große Fragen aufwirft
diese übergewinnsteuer hat in meinen in
unseren Augen wenig mit Gerechtigkeit zu
tun sie ist eher eine rechtliche
Gradwanderung
in Richtung der Bundesregierung wäre es
wichtiger gewesen die Finanzierung des
entlastungspaketes zu klären um den
jetzt entbrannten Streit mit dem
Bundesländern zu klären und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel und
auch Vertreter der Bundesregierung
setzen Sie an der richtigen Stelle an
reformieren sie das Kartellrecht ist und
schon seit weiß nicht wie viel Wochen
und Monaten zugesagt worden bringen sie
die Reform des merit order-prinzip auf
der europäische Ebene endlich schneller
voran dann können Sie die Probleme bei
der Wurzel anpacken anstatt die Symptome
durch schlecht durchdachte
Umverteilungspolitik dauerhaft ändern zu
wollen dankeschön
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges in der
Ukraine sind wir alle auf eine ganz
besondere Art und Weise gefordert viele
von uns auf eine persönliche Ebene aber
auch wir insgesamt als Gesellschaft
deswegen haben wir als Ampelkoalition
drei entlastungspakete auf dem Weg
gebracht um Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
diesen Situationen zu entlasten bei den
entlastungspaketen 1 und 2 ging das
hauptsächlich darum schnell und präzise
die Auswirkungen der Inflation
abzufedern und viele dieser
beschlossenen Maßnahmen sind gerade auf
dem Weg und kommen bei vielen Menschen
an und bei vielen Menschen macht sich da
ein spürbarer Unterschied bemerkbar
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
aber auch klar dass wir nicht die
Inflation und die Auswirkungen der
Inflation mit Einmalzahlungen und mit
pauschalen begegnen können viel mehr
wurde es auch klar dass es auch
strukturelle Eingriffe braucht das ist
strukturelle Maßnahmen braucht um dafür
zu sorgen dass wir Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dass wir unternehmen dass wir
klein und mittelständische Unternehmen
aber auch soziale Einrichtungen
unterstützen können deswegen
war es so wichtig dass wir im dritten
Entlastungspaket einen Eingriff in den
Strommarkt beschlossen haben wir haben
uns als Ampelkoalition hier deutlich
positioniert und haben klargemacht dass
wir übermäßige Gewinne zufallsgewinne
abschöpfen werden und eine
strompreisbremse einführen werden
deswegen kann ich schon sagen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Fraktion DIE LINKE der Antrag jetzt
inzwischen überflüssig würde ich sagen
sogar auf europäische Ebene gibt es
Vorschläge ich begrüße den Vorschlag der
Europäischen Kommission denn wenn man
sich die Funktionsweise der europäischen
des europäischen Strommarktes anzeigt
anschaut dann zeigt es die wichtig und
wie sinnvoll es ist die Abgabe der
zufallsgewinne gemeinschaftlich auf
EU-Ebene zu gestalten denn auf diese Art
und Weise wird sichergestellt dass
Unternehmen die durch die Krise hohe
Gewinne erzielt haben unverhoffte
Gewinne erzielt haben eine Abgabe
leisten die unabhängig erzielt wird die
unabhängig geleistet wird vom steuersitz
das heißt der Wille ist da die
politische Einigung ist da sowohl
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition als auch
auf europäische Ebene gibt es gute
Signale es geht hauptsächlich nur noch
um die Frage wie wir das umsetzen und
wir setzen uns dafür ein dass es
möglichst schnell ja aber auch
unbürokratisch klar und vor allem
rechtssicher auf dem Weg kommt die
Botschaft ist aber klar wir werden
zufallsgewinne abschöpfen
meine Vorrednerinnen und Vorredner sind
bereits auf die Begründung eingegangen
auch auf die Bemessungsgrundlage wir
hatten da eine lebhafte Diskussion
diesbezüglich ich möchte das nicht
wiederholen möchte allerdings die
verbleibende Zeit dafür nutzen um mal
der Frage nachzugehen wo die
Unterscheidung zwischen zufallsgewinne
übergewinne und normalgewinne liegt denn
in den letzten Wochen und Monate wurde
es einiges miteinander vermischt und ich
finde das ist wichtig dass hier ein
grundsätzliches gemeinsames Verständnis
darüber haben damit wir auch überhaupt
gemeinsam darüber entscheiden können was
für Instrumente es eigentlich bedarf um
diese Gewinne abzuschöpfen ich versuche
es mal mit einer Definition liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin immer
mit auf diese Reise
normalgewinne oder ein normalgewinn das
ist der Gewinn den ein Unternehmen
basierend auf Management Entscheidungen
beispielsweise in Form von Investitionen
in Form von Innovation in eine normalen
Lage erzielt das heißt wir haben hier
interne Faktoren die innerhalb eines
Unternehmens stattfinden und wir haben
externe Faktoren das was die allgemeine
Lage beeinflusst und ich würde sagen
normalgewinne passieren entsprechend
eine normale Lage ein übergewinn
hingegen ist ein deutlich höherer Gewinn
den ein Unternehmen basierend oft
Management Entscheidungen in eine
außergewöhnliche Lage erzielt und das
ist ja das was wir in den letzten Jahren
auch in der Pandemie erlebt haben dass
viele Pharmaunternehmen übergewinne
erzielt haben über diese übergewinne
stehen gegenüber dass auch gute
Entscheidung getroffen werden diese
Entscheidung stehen auch jahrelange
Investitionen in forschungenentwicklung
gegenüber diese übergewinne stehen auch
Aufbau und Erhöhung von
Produktionskapazitäten gegenüber
deswegen sind das keine leistungslose
übergewinne sondern das sind tatsächlich
gut investierte und gute Entscheidungen
die getroffen wurden und die dazu
geführt haben dass dort über gewinnen
die entstanden sind
zufallsgewinne hingegen oder ein
zufallsgewinn das ist ein deutlich
höherer Gewinn der entsteht ohne
jegliches Zutun eines Unternehmen
entsprechend Leistungslohn und
leistungslos und alleine aufgrund der
allgemeinen außergewöhnlichen Lage und
das ist ja das genau was wir gerade auf
dem Strommarkt beobachten die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben das
erwähnt aufgrund des Prinzips sehen der
doch das stromprozent Produzenten
besonders hohe Gewinne gerade erziehen
obwohl die Produktionskosten sieht
überhaupt nicht mehr verändern und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir bauen keine
normale Gewinne weiterhin besteuern
dafür haben wir schon steuern
übergewindet die wollen wir auch nicht
anpassen es geht darum diese
zufallsgewinne zu abzuschöpfen und
deswegen ist der Weg über eine Abgabe
auch der richtige Weg weil das erlaubt
uns da präzise zu sein es erlaubt uns
halt die Unternehmen genau zu anzugehen
die wir auch angehen wollen wir wollen
wir wollen und wir werden in den
Strommarkt eingreifen und die
entstehenden milliardenhohe
zufallsgewinne abschöpfen und dafür und
damit wollen wir eine strompreisbremse
auf den Weg bringen das ist ein guter
Weg viele Menschen nachhaltig in der
Krise zu unterstützen deswegen liebe
Kollegen von der Linksfraktion der
Antrag ist überflüssig und wir werden
ihn somit ablegen vielen Dank sagt am
Ort Zorn für die SPD-Fraktion ja
interessant hier während der Debatte gab
es doch diverse Rednerinnen und Redner
die definiert haben was ist eigentlich
ein übergewinn das kann ein übergewinn
sein das ist ein zufallsgewinn und die
Definition das wohl nicht überraschend
unterscheiden sich natürlich je nach
Parteizugehörigkeit
Fraktionszugehörigkeit der jeweiligen
Rednerinnen und Redner so jetzt hören
wir Robert farle er ist fraktionslos saß
bis Anfang September in der afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
der Antrag der Linken
weist schon auf ein wichtiges Problem
hin denn es kann nicht sein dass einige
Konzerne schamlos ausnutzen die
Ausplünderung der Bevölkerung um über
Ort ordentliche außerordentliche Gewinne
zu erzielen
aber ihr Antrag hat einen ganz
grundsätzlichen Mangel
und der Mangel besteht darin dass er
völlig an den Ursachen vorbeigeht und
wenn man ein Problem beseitigen will da
muss man die Ursachen lösen und das ist
das Problem der Linken dass sie immer
wieder an den Ursachen Vorbeigehen was
ist notwendig erstens wir brauchen
wieder eine echte Marktwirtschaft
bei den Strombörsen
was hier bei der CDU mit Design
gesprochen wird dieses meritsystem das
muss verschwinden weil dieses System
hebelt und auch die Strompreis bremsen
und andere bremsen und staatliche
Eingriffe das hat mit Marktwirtschaft
gar nichts aber auch überhaupt nichts zu
tun und führt nicht zu einer Lösung der
Probleme und das zweite neben der
Notwendigkeit der Marktwirtschaft ist
die Beendigung der russlandsanktionen
Nord Stream 2 muss wieder aufgemacht
werden denn hier sind die Millionen
tollen Gas die wir verschenken die wir
nicht mehr in unserem Land aufnehmen
wollen hier wird die Forderung von
Habeck umgesetzt von vor sechs Jahren
aus Russland kein Öl und kein Gas mehr
zu holen der müsste eigentlich
Freudentänze machen weil leider die
Gaslieferungen ausgeblieben sind
russland hat immer wieder erklärt und es
hat es auch noch in den letzten Wochen
erklärt die sind bereit weiter Last Cars
zu liefern und genauso wenn Sie ein Auto
kaufen müssen das bezahlen wenn Russland
liefern müssen das auch bezahlen und
dann brauchen unsere Leute nicht mehr zu
frieren
sie das sie können unsere Leute
durch den Winter kommen
und damit komme ich zum wichtigsten
Problem am Ende Zeit ist vorüber
erfahren genau ist auch eine Anzeige von
nein kein letzter Satz mehr sie sind 30
Sekunden drüber die Leute wissen was los
ist wir brauchen mehr Gas in Deutschland
und wir können fliegen bitte
Robert Falle war das als Fraktionslose
Abgeordneter hat er gesprochen da ist
die Redezeit doch sehr begrenzt also er
hatte zwei Minuten tatsächlich nur jetzt
die letzte Rednerin zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt kommt aus den Reihen
der Bündnis grünen Katrin Henneberger
ist das
solche einzustellen so dass wir der
letzten Rednerin der Debatte noch gut
zuhören können danke sehr geehrte
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
in der Debatte jetzt schon einige kluge
Dinge gesagt besonders über die
Notwendigkeit von sozialer Gerechtigkeit
mit Blick auf zufallsgewinne ich würde
gerne eine weitere Perspektive ein
weiteres Thema hinzufügen versuchen die
Debatte weiter zu fassen und zwar die
Kosten der Gewinne die Kosten der
Klimakrise
es ist keine zwei Tage her da hat der
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
in seiner Rede vor den Vereinten
Nationen sehr deutlich gemacht dass
Industrieländer aber auch die fossile
Industrie für Schäden und Verlusten der
Klimakrise aufkommen müssen besonders
auch mit Blick auf die aktuellen
zufallsgewinne der fossilen Konzerne
weltweit
eins ist klar fossile Konzerne konnten
und konnten überhaupt profitabel geführt
werden weil die Kosten von wetterextrem
von Dürren aber auch die Kosten der
unbewohnbar werdenden Regionen weil
diese nicht abgebildet werden und hätte
die Politik in den letzten Jahrzehnten
andere Rahmenbedingungen gelebt dann
wären wir jetzt schon längst unabhängig
von der Verfeuerung von Kohle Öl und Gas
es darf nicht
es darf nicht lukrativ sein mit der
Zerstörung unserer Lebensgrundlage
Gewinne zu erzielen damit wir eine
Chance haben überhaupt noch die
Klimakatastrophe aufzuhalten müssen wir
genau dies verändern und die
Erneuerbaren energienwände diesen Weg
den wir beschreiten der macht uns
unabhängig von Diktaturen der fehlt uns
nicht in Situationen wie wir sie jetzt
erleben und der sicher die
Energieversorgung von allen Menschen
es ist aber auch sehr wichtig dass wir
uns im Abbau von Klima und Umweltschutz
schädlichen Subventionen dass wir uns
diesen auch widmen die Milliarden die
brauchen nämlich jetzt auch für die
Energiewende wir brauchen Sie für eine
sozialgerechte Transformation und für
den Aufbau von Klima Resilienz und hier
da will ich sehr ehrlich sein da liegt
noch sehr viel Arbeit vor uns
aktuell erleben wir eine Flutkatastrophe
in Pakistan und eine Hungersnot und
Somalia und dies macht nur einmal mehr
deutlich wir brauchen mehr Mittel jemand
muss die Rechnung für die Klimakrise
bezahlen und da dürfen wir jene die noch
von der Verfolgung der fossilen
profitieren nicht aus der Verantwortung
entlassen
aus der Verantwortung dürfen wir fossile
Konzerne aber auch nicht entlassen bei
den wieder gutartmachungen in Regionen
die unter Fossilien exaktimismus
gelitten haben und immer noch leiden
beispielsweise
steinkohletagebauregionen in Norden von
Kolumbien der Import der erhöht sich aus
Kolumbien hat sich in diesem Jahr massiv
erhöht und auch hier müssen die Konzerne
die nun davon profitieren Verantwortung
übernehmen für die Renaturierung für die
Wiedergutmachung und für einen gerechter
Strukturwandel dort vor Ort vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Rednerin jetzt hören wir mal die
Bundestags Vizepräsidentin Yvonne
markwas schließe ich die Aussprache wir
kommen zur Beschlussempfehlung des
Finanzausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel
außerordentliche krisengewinne von
Energiekonzernen abschöpfen der
Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 24,50
den Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache 1849 abzulehnen
es liegt eine eine Erklärung zur
Abstimmung gemäß Paragraph 31
Geschäftsordnung vor die Fraktion DIE
LINKE hat namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt und die Abstimmung erfolgt in
der westlobby ich bitte die Abgeordneten
aber auch noch hier im Saal zu bleiben
da noch Überweisungen und die
abschließenden Beratungen ohne
Aussprache Folgen werden sie haben zur
Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach Eröffnung der
Abstimmung 20 Minuten
Zeit sollten wir mit den einfachen
Verfahren und den anderen Abstimmungen
noch
brauchen werden wir die Abstimmung die
namentliche Abstimmung auch noch ein
Stück verlängern
ich bitte jetzt die schriftführende
Schrift oder einzelne ich sehe ein okay
die Urnen sind besetzt und ich eröffne
die namentliche Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung die abstimmungsormen
werden
voraussichtlich um 14 Uhr
30 geschlossen so ja also Yvonne macht
was hat es hier noch mal gesagt es wird
also jetzt abgestimmt über den Antrag
der linksfraktionen die Linksfraktion
fordert ja dass ein Teil der
Unternehmensgewinne von Energiekonzernen
im Geschäftsjahr 2022 der die Gewinne
des Vorjahres um mehr als 10 Millionen
Euro übersteigt dass die mit einer
übergewinnsteuer von 25% belegte werden
wenn sie die Debatte verfolgt haben und
auch die Beschlussempfehlung aus dem
Ausschuss dann scheint es doch recht
sicher dass dieser Antrag keine Mehrheit
findet die Redner der Ampelkoalition die
haben ja hier in der Aussprache deutlich
gemacht dass die Ampel sich ja im
dritten Entlastungspaket darauf gelegt
hat dass sie zufallsgewinne bei
stromerzeuern abschöpfen möchte da
schaut man aber erst und das ist das
nächste Datum auf den 30 September dann
gibt es ein Treffen der
eu-energieminister wo dann über einen
Vorschlag der Kommission abgestimmt wird
der eine europaweite Abschöpfung der
übergewinne vorsieht erst dann wird man
genau wissen wie es dann in Deutschland
weiter